there is not a better time to support
Muslim owned businesses anaka is one of
them simple modest and elegant buy
simple elegant modest wear online at
anaka inspired your ultimate destination
for Quality modest clothing from open
the bias to close the Biers discover a
Cate discover a created selection that
defines Timeless Styles they also sell
th for brothers and UT and hijabs
brother and sisters support and buy your
loved ones elegant modest clothing now
check them out in the link in
description box below Alum brothers and
sisters and dear friends so as you guys
know Sky News took down their video and
if you listen to their video at first
brother sisters which we're going to
react to which you're going to see for
yourself they objectively covering the
news which they should be doing so this
is their job their job should not be
taking sides they should be objectively
covering a news regardless of public
opinion or anyone's opinion for that
matter so obviously we know with Israel
they believe anyone that's been
objective is smort is important Kamas so
here is a comparison of the deleted
footage compared to how it was before
we're going to watch for ourselves insh
and ask our a simple question why would
one find the need to cover an objective
news to know that these Hooligans these
Zionist Thugs who were chanting racism
islamophobia attacking C drivers ripping
down um Palestinian Flags which are
covered in my other video not only that
attacking bystanders like your general
Dutch people uh for that matter so here
is the clip let's was ourselves in and
have a comparison in so here is the clip
five people injured and dozens have been
arrested but what happened supporters of
Israeli football club makabe Tel Aviv
arrived in Amsterdam ahead of their UFA
Europa League match against Amsterdam
Club ax on Wednesday social media videos
verified by Sky News show makabe Tel
Aviv fans tearing down Palestinian flags
from outside of homes other social media
videos appeared to show residents
chasing makabe
Tel on Thursday just before the game
crowds of makabe fans were filmed
singing racist and anti-arab
[Music]
songs while a pro Palestinian
demonstration had been banned by the
mayor over fears there would be clashes
later that evening during the match
Israeli supporters appeared to disrupt
the minute silence for Valencia flood
victims with
whistles and fireworks McVey fans were
seen attacking locals as a police car
can be seen driving by so what you guys
saw there was the actual coverage of the
news now here is the clips which I'm
going to show you guys inshah of how
they changed the title and the orator
has also changed so here is it in let's
watch this now in Amsterdam left at
least five people injured maab fans were
seen attacking locals as a police car
can be seen driving by a video posted on
social media shows a large group of
hooded men dressed in black running down
the street and striking people at random
violence in Amsterdam left at least five
people in violence in Amsterdam left at
least five people injured so guys what
you saw there is a direct editing and
not only that they took the video down
and then they edited it why do they find
they need to do this so you see brother
and sisters in this life as you can see
Subhan Allah in on it says first it was
Israel Israeli football fans attacked in
Amsterdam yes okay firstly that's not
true they were not attacked they were
attacking then they changed the whole
title to because the beginning is
rubbish anyways before was rubbish
anyways now they use the anti-semitic
card which has no value anymore because
they've just used it so much the biggest
threat for Jews is Zionism for that
matter yeah what we know about
anti-semitic violence in Amsterdam so
before it was who the fans who they
actually were then it went to a group of
people being violent Etc so the question
is brothers and sisters that we need to
ask ourself is that when it comes to
these issues Justice sometimes we look
for justice in this life sometimes we're
like okay you know I want justice
justice justice sometimes having Allah
and Trust in Allah subhana wa tala is
that Justice is going to serve better in
the Hereafter okay and sometimes we
think that with Justice it has to be
done in with our own hands I need to go
and seek Justice I need to go out my way
true of course but sometimes leaving
Justice to the hand of Allah subhana wa
tala Allah works in mysterious ways of
implementing that and Subhan Allah this
is a form of sometimes you know what you
do you say oh Allah I have been wronged
I have been oppressed I'm leaving the
matters in your hand and let Allah
subhana deal with the oppressors whoever
they may be so on the day of judgment
brother and sisters every sub everyone
will get to account like Allah says in
the Quan zah every single atom of weight
of good and bad that you've done will be
given to you and then Allah subhana T
tells us that the disbelievers the enemy
the Hostile disbelievers who disbelieved
and were the wrongdoers when they get
the book on their left or their back
they will say wo unto us what kind of a
book is this that it has not missed
anything small or big can you imagine
giving a book of your deeds and you look
and thinking how on Earth has it got
that one little thing that I did you're
going to be amazed and that's how Allah
subhana tal accounts every single atom
of good or bad you do is going to be
accounted for so do not everything for a
second the media the whole world coming
against Palace or whatever it's not
going to change nothing in this life
they might get away but in the here of
there's going to be a price paid but
alhamdulillah Allah's Mercy like we said
it's in the D yes Allah's Rah yes he's
given to us Subhan Allah even
non-muslims are waking up to the reality
of the Zionist propaganda everyone has
seen through them you have never seen in
history of the past 7 years what they've
been doing to the Palestinians that now
we have social media nobody's buying it
anymore back in the days it would be
open BBC or Sky News and they tell us
what to think and see not anymore real
footage is coming out showing what they
were doing you cannot get away and it
further makes the cause of the
Palestinians greater and furthers the
the the hatred against Zionism which
they themselves deserve that's all I
want to cover from s inshallah may Allah
subh make us among those who speak the
truth and Allah tells us speak the truth
even is against yourself your kin and
not only Muslims even non-muslims are
implementing this Ayah till next time